of diplomatic hand-grenade from Donald
Trump he broke all the rules of
international diplomacy he refused to
budge on terrace he refused to have a
one-on-one meeting with Theresa May I
mean doesn't really signify that we
really don't matter head to him very
much at the moment I don't think so and
if you look back at the response to the
nerve agent attack in Salisbury you can
see how with the diplomatic support that
we've got that Teresa made the Prime
Minister rallied including the Americans
and actually when when it really counts
we've got those strong ties and and that
the bind on security and other things
and of course the Prime Minister has
been over and met with Donald Trump on a
number of occasions now and we've talked
about all the positive things that we
that we have in common
equally when there's a necessity to say
where we don't agree I think the Prime
Minister's got the resolve to do so but
obviously I think at the moment if you
look at what happened over in Canada we
all to be saying and the UK has got a
very important voice the free trade is
benefits everyone and protectionism
hurts everyone and I think that's the
message from the UK he's certainly an
unusual figure to deal with Donald Trump
Boris Johnson was recorded LEEP comments
from their doors Boris Johnson earlier
this week saying that perhaps Theresa
May could learn one or two things from
Donald Trump style of leadership maybe
if he's in charge of BRICS that would be
getting somewhere she'll agree with this
assessment well I think that's silly
really but look all of these things when
you're at a private dinner can get taken
out of context blown out of all
proportion I think the Prime Minister's
got the right team the right approach
and we're going up to the June council
and we where we're going to be
discussing trade talks which is
crucially important for the UK but also
for the EU and we need to be focused on
the substance of that and getting the
best deal for the whole country now I
want to talk to you about the Granville
Tower anniversary with your housing mr.
hat on now that's convenient next week a
year on it since hauling fire that left
those households are homeless the
government said that it would rehouse
permanently every single household
within a year so how many households are
still waiting for help
look first of all it's going to be a
very difficult time one year on from
that appalling unimaginable tragedy and
we need to stand in solidarity with the
community with the bereaved and with the
survivors in terms of the support that
we're providing we've got now all but
five of the 203 households from the
tower in the walk who have either moved
into temporal permanent accommodation or
who have accepted a move it hasn't
happened quick enough I'm the first to
say and we're straining every sinew to
provide the support and work with the
community and work with the council
which is in the lead on this to make it
happen as soon as possible but there has
been sight of that I'm listening to what
you're saying then you're talking about
people who are in temporary housing who
have accepted offers these are not
people who have moved into permanent new
homes which is what the government
promised I mean as Housing Minister do
you feel ashamed of that so I didn't
catch that last question there's a hymns
being played in the background here and
I'm saying that you're talking about
people there who are in temporary
housing and also people who have only
accepted moves for permanent homes not
people who are in permanent new housing
so aren't you ashamed that as housing
minister oh I feel terrible for all
aspects of what the community has been
through and it's crucial that we get as
much support to them as possible of
course it's a challenge because the
amount and the type of housing stock in
the area is limited and the councillors
bought I think it's 300 or over 300 new
properties so there's been choices that
have been given to all of the households
but you're right I feel sorry for that
community and I'm very happy to
apologize that we haven't done it
quickly enough but it's not right to say
that there hasn't been important
progress and I'm confident that we can
keep making progress and of course those
homes once they've been purchased need
to be made need to be renovated in some
cases and they need to be right for the
individual household some of them have
special needs or disabilities and we
need to get that right but of course I
want it done as soon as possible let's
talk about brexit and the other of
course a big challenge our faith in the
government at the car
time and I went to Dover this week and
have to say what I found there made me
feel a bit worried the head of the poor
today they're saying for example that
just a two minute extra time on Lori's
been checked and going through customs
could lead to 17 miles of kids I mean
are you worried about the lack of
progress that's been made on brexit well
I think we've made important progress
with the EU withdrawal bill that's gone
through the Commons and now the Lord's
and we've got it back to look at again
in the Commons on the diplomatic front
we got that first phase deal important
for securing the rights of EU nationals
here UK nationals on the continent and
we got the implementation period so of
course I want to say is get cracking and
that's what the June counts will allow
us to do in terms of progressing to
trade talks so we've made important
progress but yes we need to to get on
with this now and what we're offering to
the EU is the win-win of a free trade
set of arrangements which is good for
them good for us particularly this time
as we've been talking about where
there's protectionist noises coming from
the US and other quarters and we
actually need to be standing up for free
trade and the worst thing now will be to
see trade barriers go up between the UK
and the EU so that's the win-win we're
looking for and yes we've got still some
hard yards to go but we have made
important progress as well you talked
there about the need to crack on and
this is at a time when the brexit
secretary was rumoured to be on the
brink of resignation last week when
Boris Johnson's had yet more
embarrassing comments that leaked her to
their newspapers do you think we could
do with a bit more cabinet discipline a
bit more people getting behind the Prime
Minister yes very simple answer what
would you say to those slightly unruly
colleagues of yours them well look
otherwise spoke to Dave days last week
with no discussion of resignations at
all just about the work and the progress
we're doing towards that June Council
with the EU I think everyone needs to
get behind the Prime Minister I thought
it was interesting reading and Barad
former Home Secretary and remain
campaigner teaming up with the in Duncan
Smith cabinet member form a former
cabinet member and leave campaign and
saying look this you with legislation
that we're putting through and getting
passed through the House of Commons
again this week is crucially important
we need a united front we need to show
as a government and also as a country
that we're bigger than the sum of our
and I think we'll get that legislation
through I'm reasonably confident that we
will do that but we need to work
together from backbenchers right the way
through to the top team now we haven't
got long left on the interview but there
is one more thing I quote keen to ask
you very loyal to Teresa may they have
been listening to what you've been
saying we've had a lot of cabinet
resignations you keep being touted for a
top job you haven't quite made it into
cabinet yet have you so what do you
think Teresa Moe's got against you you
know I'm not going to comment on that
trees amazed the boss she picks their
top team and you know what I'm delighted
to be working on the housing brief we've
got last year we saw homeownership rise
for the first time in 13 years that's
crucial for lower middle-income families
for teachers for nurses for the next
generation that want to get on the
housing ladder so I've got enough on my
plate without worrying about what that
okay thank you very much dominate